o pessoal bem 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma pistola usam molas de uma dela
e provável que você já tenha visto algum
brinquedo por sido mas não no formato
que eu vou ensinar vos é o brinquedo que
vocês já viram tem vários anos de
existência na internet mas não sabe ao
certo quem criou então não posso deixar
ele tem uma vez que não sei quem
realmente eu estava ter sido eu a criar
isto mas não fui
é então eu não vou mentir mas enfrenta
esta parte da empreendedora e acho que
com muito melhor o projeto é uma vez que
foi o empreendedor e muito mais fácil
disparar e arma fica mais sólido assim
na mão aqui
assim essa dá pra apontar melhor coisa
que você tem que fazer é de montar uma
mola e vão precisar de desenhar está nas
partes de maneira muito rápida nos traz
para essa pausa e vocês design assim de
guarín para ter esta partida vocês têm
que ter muito cuidado e caso sejam
crianças têm que pedir ajuda a um adulto
de certeza que não vai importar de nos
ajudar
inicialmente em tirar este rectângulo e
depois fazer este canal para ser mais
fácil você faça um corte de 90 graus ou
seja um corte porque da ldu e do design
depois faça um corte inclinados para
intercetar com os cortes em 90 graus e
assim pronto é mais fácil tirar pra
finalizar lincoln chavo só tirar é
naquelas obras e este fica tudo mais
luizinho tem que fazer a outra parte o
procedimento na parte do canal é igual
ou seja faça lhe corta 90 graus um lado
ao outro do outro lado e depois fazer
cinco cortes inclinados a aceitar os
cortes 90 graus
tem que ter amor ao contrário ele terá
esses pequenos pedacinhos
vocês podem ver melhor aqui vermelho até
aqui e agora deixar uma parte na outra
ele tem que certificar que está tudo bem
feito antes a partido político tem que
andar livremente estiver tudo certinho é
só coar uma parte a outra eu vou usar
uma super cola mas vocês podem usar
contra escolas com a esquerda quer pode
usar cola pv a cola de madeira que quase
a mesma coisa mas enfim pode ser
encarado de frente é estão coca-cola
sério
o importante é que ela não transborda
parte dos canais internos seja não podem
usar na cola para encaixar a para da
empreendedora você inicialmente tem que
fazer este corte aqui que eu ganhei
depois ele tenha informado corretamente
triangular e vejam o ângulo se
aproximado para fazer a parte da
incubadora tem que juntar a uma para
amolar outra vez aqui super cola tem que
fazer duas partes com mais aqui
já fiz aqui outra pois tem claro uma
parte a outra ponto cola só lina para
tanguá
o primeiro fica demasiado grande se
vocês deixarem sim
convém que vocês cortem é o tamanho de
ficar certo para a vossa mãe fazer e se
usa uma serra para metal com salazar era
total e não usar aquela para a matéria
mesmo porque o corte não fica tão
preciso uma vez que os dentes era normal
são muito grande que tem que usar um
pouco da cola se encaixe em boa parte na
outra
para finalizar é só encaixar aquela para
que disse para vocês mudarem para o
final da arma
o que é algo que um clima difícil
atendendo claro das molas que vocês
usarem mas esta parte aqui do irã das
minhas bolas eram bastante lixo e
domingo você se encaixa em uma coisa só
se vocês forem usar isso tem que usar
óculos de proteção e tem que ser
bastante responsáveis porque tem alguma
força ok e não aponta contra mim é igual
proteção pode usar o sol também certa e
pronta a disparar vejo aqui uma pistola
normal que estivesse pronta fechar um
gatinho e já está
só espero que o estado se vocês quiserem
ajudar o canal é só deixar um like e se
inscrevam caso não sejam inscritos que
tiver alguma sugestão do projeto é só
deixar nos comentários que vai depois
tenta fazer como sempre o fez bater ao i
amanhã